yesterday I deleted my video let's talk
about that
[Music]
this video just gotta monetize damn
psycho kimochi ni da da Cara Simba Hana
still abstain de are you working for
YouTube now I [ __ ] knew it
I am making $3,000 a month from fans
from followers from viewers God what do
I call you
Rose I'm gonna try and get these money
refunded I'm not keeping them am i
keeping them is it wrong for me to keep
them two people paid a thousand bucks
for me to follow them on Twitter that's
[ __ ] insane I didn't [ __ ] I didn't
realize that and I'll throw in a nice
message like happy birthday
please poke holes for enter to breathe
while you ship him here thanks oh hell
no if Edgar arrives dead that's your
problem
my fellow patrons this is a scam oh no
no no no no it's not you do not I repeat
you do not need to pay $1 to be able to
subscribe to poopyface channel I was to
subscribe every 40 open up a tree oh
don't be like me and don't fall for the
lies god bless
don't hey Martin no I think this patron
was a joke but I took it seriously okay
alright I'm avi I don't want to just
donate 2,000 grand if people wanted to
give me that money
so I'll get it refunded I'll write to
patreon I don't know four thousand four
thousand how did it must have gone up
right now I swear to god it was not four
thousand what the [ __ ] is happening oh I
see patreon takes a little cut yeah that
is that is pretty pretty slimy ain't it
you know I could I could [ __ ] quit
YouTube and just live off my patreon now
this is great
well Plan B has been sorted guys okay
so yesterday I deleted my video a lot of
people freaked out about it I didn't
think it was that big a deal I just
didn't like the video and a lot of
people treat it as as if like he's just
stressed out oh my god I think he's
slowly having a meltdown
I've had it since the beginning okay for
me wasn't that big a deal I just thought
it was a really shitty video I don't
want to make any more shitty videos I
made three thousand videos okay let's go
through some more deleted videos I'm
actually curious cuteness over 9000 oh
yeah I never uploaded this one let me
see what's wrong with this video welcome
my name is - dandy or a brief glimpse
into this silly like not a bad video I
just didn't like it I guess I deleted
the YouTube drama video remember that
one where I said I hate drama and now
I'm causing more drama than I have ever
done because I'm a major [ __ ]
hypocrite and now I try to hide it well
by deleting the video this video never
made it up like if it's called test what
the [ __ ] is this
okay I think I understand
[Music]
oh my gosh thank God I didn't show that
one on the Internet Jesus Christ
Hasegawa I go to this one I think I just
played a lot of like meet it very poorly
made horror games and I didn't like it
yeah I'm all about quality of my channel
guys I'm so picky whatever goes up has
to be the finest of the farm like a fine
wine baby you just got a sip on it and a
little bit kind of make it sing that's
that's the put a pie channel just think
of like a like a 50 year old man with a
moustache and glasses who just then we
just gets a little bit vapor I never
upload this is a really cool horror game
what happened what went wrong
[Music]
make some frustration and terror you
thought I didn't enjoy playing this any
I think that just shows so well and I
don't want to do these type of idiots
I don't know if I'm gonna like the video
before the game before I play it I think
that's why I don't really do that much
gameplay anymore because I don't really
know if I'm gonna like the game before I
play it that can be really frustrating
and I don't really have that much time I
know I'm a very busy man got a lot of
stuff to do but I really don't have that
much time to record every single day
just play games every single [ __ ] day
I'm sorry I don't have time for
everyone's just complaining why does it
make plot not play more games I will
play more games if good games comes out
have you thought about that
I'm sharda what's a great game you enjoy
that [ __ ] didn't you don't you want to
wait for good games or do you rather
want to see me play shitty games all the
[ __ ] time because I'm tired of it I'm
tired of all this
too many shitty games markiplier play
games all the time
check septic I
place games all the time Diamond
Minecraft plays minecraft every single
day do you think he doesn't want a
suicide do you think he want to keep on
living this horrible life do you think
you want to make these faces for the
thumbnails tobyGames
do you think he wants to do 400 parts of
happy wheels why do you think he just
drugs but no it's not enough for you
more games more happy wheels look what
you did do you think Oprah hack sir no
one wants to make these faces every day
do you really think that me Sean that
game was so [ __ ] and I played through
the whole [ __ ] thing oh my life is so
hard okay I'm gonna play more games if I
want to play the games I think that's
the problem a lot of the times you can
make the video more entertaining by
editing it and adding funny memes but at
the end of the day you can't hide how
[ __ ] hard you're trying to make it
interesting and that is this video that
I deleted yesterday and it's entirely
Oh holy [ __ ] I told you what let's check
out some more videos I deleted why did I
delete this I did not delete this go you
should be bowing jack is in it that
makes sense Oh God
what that [ __ ] are you doing is oh man
those are some hilarious faces you're
pulling there oh boy oh the tongue met
the tongue I can't no I can't I'm sorry
sorry I can't watch this [ __ ] I rather
die I would rather die this is a video I
did just for Marzia some have some other
people found it that's private we used
to send video messages oh that's a good
memory okay look how cute I was before
no wonder I got marks yeah yeah bring
the dog in there nice move Felix oh no
not that one
why am i playing a game playing the
background of a game play as in
questions unedited for 20 minutes and
why do I have the same [ __ ] haircut
now Jesus Christ is my old maybe you
didn't know this but I started off doing
call of duty game playing did the entry
even back then I have a couple updates
important updates I want to talk about
but first of all I want to say you're
awesome I get so many people writing to
me game and I went 26 and 3 I don't
think I'll ever see I've ever seen
anyone else I don't get the yeah no one
else has gone in a tweet 26 3kd
PewDiePie you're definitely the only one
in the [ __ ] universe be fair I was
gonna be him though and I was pretty
[ __ ] ball mass at it look at this
[ __ ] last kill I remember I was so
[ __ ] proud look at this hell yeah
hell yeah you couldn't pull that [ __ ]
off to save your [ __ ] life oh yeah my
[ __ ] just dance videos
okay I was so proud of these because
everyone did the same thing on YouTube
back then like for me to play just dance
was like whoa this guy's thinks outside
the box
I'm sweat I'm sweating this is pit you
don't understand how painful this is
there's some videos with [ __ ] 500
views
good mean
[Music]
hilarious good meme pr2 pie oh yeah I
had the whole series of blank dream I
never published it I forgot about it
it's a good game this is a great example
when people say my videos were better
before my very first video and it's not
actually up on my channel but this is my
very first video sorry
oh my Swedish accent is so strong I have
it nerd
learned it yet sorry I haven't learned
it yet so sorry I'm Swedish I I haven't
learned how to do well YouTube yet he
said that he was top of the leaderboards
in zombies and I am booty pie welcome to
my video you know in like five years I'm
gonna be here again reacting to this
video and cringing equally what can I
say
YouTube is a beautiful thing oh hey uh
well I should kill yourself oh [ __ ] I
remember this I thought it was so cool
hutch and seananners and Sarek and we're
like talking about me that was just like
well I made it now boys I'm in the big
league now thank you very much oh so
yeah I have a ton of videos deleted and
I'm gonna delete a lot more so don't
worry about I'm just at the point where
I've gotten more out of youtube than I
ever wanted that was not correct more
than I ever expected from now on I feel
like if I don't put out stuff that I'm
happy with then what's the point you
know that's really my main focus I don't
care about more subscribers I don't
really care about all the rest of the
[ __ ]
I just want to make videos that I feel
happy with so thank you for
understanding that and
hope this video explained it leave a
like for more likes because I do really
care about those and I'll see you brush
in the next video it's always bro-bro
theists the pretty good bargain for five
dollars you get this runescape image I
think that's a pretty good offer seven
bucks if you pledge seven dollars you
get angry alright just [ __ ] take it
you know what
he's free I don't want him [ __ ]
that's his penis get out of that what
are you doing any more ideas for patron
usual juice look at adapt you place
puffiness in Duga Dido I should just
look at other Pro people's profile and
do what they did genius let's do that